[Musique]
bonjour en 2014 on comptait 600 millions
d'obèses dans le monde
cela représente 13 % des adultes obèses
plus de femmes que d'hommes en france en
france le nombre de personnes obèses a
doublé en 15 ans il est passé de 3
millions et demi en 1997 à presque 7
millions en 2012 quinze pour cent des
adultes français sont obèses l'obésité
est une maladie des pauvres dans les
pays riches est une maladie des riches
dans les pays pauvres
en effet les couples qui gagnent plus de
300 3800 euros par mois ont un taux
d'obésité faible en quinze ans il a
évolué de 5 à 8% alors que les coupes
dans le revenu minimum est de 1200 euros
par mois ont vu leur fréquence doublé
s'est passé de 12 à 24 %
béziers est une des villes les plus
pauvres de france
mais par contre le taux d'obésité n'est
pas très élevé en effet avec 15 6 %
d'obèses
le languedoc roussillon est loin
derrière le nord de la france l'est de
la france
le centre de la france pourtant alors
qu'il y à peu d'obèses
on y opère trois fois plus qu'ailleurs
pourquoi en fait
béziers est une ville du sud de la
france il fait beau 300 jours par an on
y va à la plage on s'y promène peu
vêtues l'apparence a de l'importance
le regard de l'autre aussi je suis
chirurgien bariatrique à béziers j'opère
les obèses les gros obèses ont défini
quatre stade d'obésité selon l' indice
de masse corporelle qui est calculé en
fonction du poids et de la taille
l'obésité modérée quand l' indice de
masse corporelle est à entre 30 et 35
l'obésité sévère lorsqu'elle est entre
35 et 40 et l'obésité morbide
lorsque cet indice de masse corporelle
est supérieur à 40 par exemple pour une
personne de 1 m 65
c'est lorsque le poids dépasse 109 kg
qu'elle est en obésité morbide une
nouvelle catégorie est apparue une sous
catégorie de l'obésité morbide c'est
l'obésité massive
lorsque l'imc est supérieur à 50 en
france on n'opère que l'obésité morbide
donc dont l'imc super à 40 cela
représente 550 mille personnes est
également l'obésité sévère si elle est
compliqué de comorbidité c'est-à-dire de
diabète d'hypertension d' atteinte
articulaire sévère ou d'apnée du sommeil
ça représente un million et demi de
personnes en tout presque deux millions
de personnes pourraient avoir accès à
cette intervention
on estime qu'en 2020 il y aura eu cinq
cent mille interventions de chirurgie de
l'obésité pratiqué en france
la sleeve gastrectomie est
l'intervention la plus fréquemment
pratiquée elle consiste à enlever les
deux tiers de l'estomac
cela conduit à avoir un petit estomac et
en plus la partie qu'on lève qu'on
enlève contient les hormones de
l'appétit donc les gens n'ont pas faim 1
j'ai pas faim 2 quand je mange je suis
très vite rassasié cela explique
l'efficacité de cette intervention qui
entraîne une perte de poids de 25 à 35
kg
à deux ans j'ai été interpellé en 2015
par un article canadien qui va un petit
peu impressionné par ce qu'il disait que
dans les suites opératoires le risque de
suicide après chirurgie de l'obésité et
est 50% plus élevé qu'avant chirurgie je
m'attendais à des résultats inverses les
gens maigri il corrige corps mobilité
pourquoi ce résultat peut-être parce que
quand les gens viennent nous consulter
il ne faut pas être du oui ils veulent
maigrir pour un problème de santé mais
ils veulent parfois et parfois surtout
également maigrir pour leur apparence
effectivement quand on perd beaucoup de
fois en moyenne c'est effectivement une
trentaine de kilos dans quelques mois
napo n'a pas tendance à bien se retendre
alors ils peuvent avoir à faire à la
chirurgie plastique réparatrice qu'on
appelle la chirurgie alouettes
vous connaissez la chirurgie alouettes
n'ont la chirurgie alouettes qu'on
pratique après les amaigrissement massif
c'est et les bras et les bras et les
saints et les seins et le ventre et le
ventre et les cuisses et les cuisses
alouettes et cette chirurgie non
seulement est multiple mais elle
entraîne de longues et disgracieuse
cicatrices se poser la question la peau
pourquoi est ce que ne se rendant pas
automatiquement lorsqu'on maigri
pourquoi est-ce que lorsqu on maigrit
beaucoup en peu de temps la peau ne se
retint pas je vais essayer de vous
l'expliquer pour commencer il faut
savoir que l'alimentation représente un
apport de calories
ces calories vont servir à deux choses
premièrement assuré le métabolisme basal
se dire le fonctionnement habituel du
corps et deuxièmement elles vont servir
à faire que je puisse faire tous ces
mouvements assurer toute la gestuelle
quand l'apport calorique est réduit
qu'est ce qui se passe on pourrait se
dire tiens le corps va aller piocher
dans les réserves
pas du tout il va d'abord commencer à
économiser sur quoi il va économiser
sur toute l'énergie que je dépense en
gestuelle et comment il va le faire très
simple il va vous mettre fatigué vous
serez fatigué ce qui limitera vos
mouvements
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui ont fait des
régimes l'ont bien noté
quand on commence un régime on est
fatigué si là pour si on poursuit son
amaigrissement et que la ration
calorique ne s'améliore pas le corps va
effectivement puiser dans ses réserves
mais attention en même temps qu'il va
commencer à puiser dans ses réserves
il va essayer d'augmenter les apports
pour arrêter justement de puiser dans
ses réserves
alors là je vous écrire trois mécanismes
qui l'utilisent il y en a plusieurs
le premier c'est l'exacerbation des sens
alors qu'est ce que c'est en termes
simples
en termes simples score va baisser son
niveau d'exigence en même temps qu'il va
mettre tous les sens en a l'air vous
seriez passer devant un croissant rassis
avant votre régime ou n'y aurait même
pas accordé la moindre importance mais
là en déficit de calories ce croissant
vous allez le trouver appétissant et
quand vous allez manger vous allez même
arriver à le trouver bon et ça ça va là
pour toutes les odeurs qui vont vous
entoure et pour tout ce que vous allez
voir en la vie moderne où on est
tellement harcelée par tout ce qu'on
voit tout ce qu'on entend tout ce qu'on
sent la résistance devient difficile
deuxième possibilité de mécanismes pour
le corps
c'est en temps normal quand vous allez
dans un buffet que vous avez le choix
entre une salade à fabre a un faible
apport calorique et les chiffres des
cacahuètes
vous avez réellement le choix sauf qu'en
cas de réduction calories
le corps ne vous laisse plus le choix il
va vous précipiter sur les aliments à
plus fort apport calorique et donc il va
vous précipiter sur les chiffres et les
cacahuètes pour pouvoir amener les
calories plus important de façon plus
importante au corps troisième chose vous
savez qu'en temps normal le cerveau au
bout de vingt minutes reçoit
l'information de l'estomac comme quoi il
faut qu'il s'arrête de manger
qu'est ce que va faire le corps pendant
ces 20 minutes eh ben il va essayer de
faire rentrer le plus d'alimentation
possible et il va vous faire manger
beaucoup plus vite
tous ces mécanismes sont faits pour
augmenter la ration calorique
oui mais voilà si vous continuez à
perdre du poids parce que vous n'avez
pas une ration calorique suffisante
quel est le stade ultérieur le stade
ultérieur
ça va être la destruction de votre masse
musculaire et pourquoi parce qu'il faut
savoir que le muscle consomme la plupart
de la ration calorique quotidienne
et là le corps gagne sur deux tableaux 1
il va plus avoir à entretenir ce muscle
qui consomment une ration calorique
importante mais deux n'ayant plus de bus
vous pourrez pas faire de mouvements
particuliers et on va rentrer maintenant
dans le plus fin et c'est là qu'il faut
comprendre où la peau va être concerné
si vous poursuivez effectivement votre
insuffisances d'apport calorique
qu'est ce que va faire le corps il va se
sentir menacé dans sa survie alors il va
installer une protection pour les
organes nobles
tout ce que vous allez manger vallée aux
organes nobles le coeur les reins le
cerveau le foie mais alors quoi et bien
alors les organes qui ne sont pas noble
eux ils n'auront plus rien qui sont ces
organes pas noble les cheveux mes poils
et et la peau exactement
cette peau qui ne sera plus nourris
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire que vous
soyez jeunes que vous soyez vieux hommes
femmes
si elle n'est plus nourris elle ne se
retendre apa alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
le premier moyen c'est d'apporter par
voie orale
tout ce que la peau va pouvoir accepter
pour être nourri mais il ne faut pas que
ce soit des choses qui soient préemptées
par les organes nobles
donc c'est tous les aliments que la peau
pourra intégrer et qu'ils ne sont
destinées qu'à la peau ou co cheveux
pendant la première année après la sig
gastrectomie on met en place une
supplémentation vitaminique qui permet
d'apporter douze principes actifs
différents qui vont favoriser la
repousse des poils et des cheveux l'art
tente de la peau et une meilleure race
élasticité à ce niveau en fait on s'est
également aperçu que on pouvait avoir un
autre moyen d'action puisque ce qui
passe par la bouche ils n'y arrivent pas
à la peau pourquoi ne pas utiliser la
voie locale
vous voyez tout sa longueur de publicité
à la télévision
ces crèmes enrichi en collagène qui nous
permette la régénération de la peau est
tout ouïe mais ça quand vous avez une
alimentation normale l'alimentation vous
apporte ce que vous avez besoin donc ces
crèmes sont pas très utiles
al'inverse en cas d'insuffisance
d'apport et encore plus en cas
d'insuffisance de nutrition de la peau
alors là ça peut être important et
intéressant d'avoir des crèmes et des
huiles qui nous aident
ce n'est pas tout l'impôt on le sait
comme vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure sur
les images si vous la laisse et elle
tombe alors on a mis en place un
vêtements compressifs sur mesure qu'on
appelle la seconde pour rosa se
vêtements compressifs sur mesure et
corps entier il doit être porté tous les
jours pendant deux ans il va
effectivement empêché l'impôt de tomber
par le système de la compression le
temps qu'on retrouve une alimentation
capable de nourrir la peau et donc de
lui permettre de se retendre
un travail sur l'image du corps l estime
de soi est entrepris avec le psychiatre
parce qu'effectivement c'est une
démarche essentielle pour que les
patients prennent soin quotidiennement
de leur corps et qu'ils ne se
découragent pas enfin bien sûr quand on
veut que la surface soit bonne il faut
travailler le sous sol
le sous sol c'est la masse musculaire
démarche collective voilà l'ensemble des
moyens qu'on a mis en place le résultat
c'est que depuis janvier 2013 soit
depuis presque quatre ans aucune des
personnes que nous avons opéré de sliv
gastrectomie n'a eu besoin d'avoir
recours à la chirurgie plastique de
retente abdominale type abdominoplastie
ou total body leaf aucune non plus ne
s'est suicidé je vous propose de voir
quelques chemins de vie le premier celui
d'yvette et sébastien yvette quand elle
est rentrée dans le réseau elle peser
199 points 7 kg presque 200 kilos et
elle marchait pas plus que 500 m elle a
perdu 115 kg on est à trois ans de 7
livres gastrectomie mais en plus elle
est devenue coach sportif dans le réseau
rosa puisque maintenant elle arrive à
marcher à sept kilomètres heure en
marche nordique son compagnon sébastien
lui a perdu 45 kg oui mais voilà lui il
n'a pas été opéré
lui il a suivi juste la rose attitude
c'est à dire l'ensemble de ses moyens
qu'on met en place qui permettent de
changer de façon de vivre
finalement avec ou sans chirurgie le
traitement de l'apparence dans l'obésité
est une nécessité absolue
si on veut aider les obèses à modifier
leur chemin de vie durablement
donnons leur la chance de s'aimer
donnons leur la chance d'aimer leurs
nouveaux corps afin qu'ils soient prêts
à faire tous les efforts nécessaires
pour défendre le résultat de leur
courageuse démarche
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]